hello my name is Bruno Oliveira and I'm
an engineer in the play games team and -
in today's EV bytes episode we're going
to talk about a problem that comes up
very often in multiplayer games and that
is of course how do you choose who goes
first
remember that multiplayer is symmetrical
so no one is naturally special there's
no server or anything like that but
sometimes you need to choose one of the
players to be to have a special role
like to be the judge of a match to make
the first move you already need to
decide whose player one who's player two
and so on so how do you do this
your first thought looking at the API
may be oh let me use the the rooms
creator so the player who's good who's
the creator of the room is gonna be the
judge or is gonna make the first move
etc that's generally a bad idea and
that's a bad idea because there's a
funny thing that happens in automatch
because automatically means I will we
get a whole bunch of rooms and put them
together into a single room so when you
have automatic lairs in the room there
will there will not necessarily be
agreement on who was the rooms creator
so that's so that doesn't work as
expected so you may think okay I'm gonna
use the player ID right so everyone has
a player ID I'm just gonna sort the
player IDs and whoever has the lowest
priority is gonna be the first to play
again that's a bad idea because when you
have automatic players you don't have
access to the pleiades of those
automatch players so that method doesn't
work either okay what if you just use
participant IDs that's a slightly better
idea because everyone has a participant
ID however that's still none not very
good and why okay let's suppose you're
doing something like this so you get
everyone's participant IDs which are
these funny strings you sort that list
and then you pick that first player on
that list to be to start the game or to
be the king or to have that special role
sure that works and definitely
everyone's gonna agree on who has that
special role but here's the problem so a
participant ID is not really a random
string it actually has some structure to
it it's encoded information so suppose
that I'm that last guy over there and
I'm unlucky enough that in every single
match that i play my participant ID
begins with a Z so if if I'm not lucky
enough that happens then no matter how
many matches I play I'll never get to
play further so I never get to be the
king you'll never get that special role
in the game so the game might be very
very boring for me so we definitely
don't want that to happen so one of the
ways you
you can solve the problem he is your
sort the participant the list of
participant that he says before then he
picks the first player on that list but
that player is not gonna played the
special role his only responsibility is
going to be to randomly choose who's
going to be the king or to play first
after choosing that using some some sort
of like fair method all you have to do
is then broadcast to the other players
that that selection and then everyone's
gonna agree that that player is gonna be
the king or the leader and and the
choice was fair so no one had had the
privilege of being the king many times
so and then everyone agrees and now all
we have to hope is that f zero to nine
is gonna be a wise ruler that's gonna
lead your game into an age of peace and
prosperity that was it for today's dev
bytes thank you